[Musique]
les américains revendiquent une partie
du groenland séparé du reste du pays par
un canal mais personne ne l'a encore
prouvé nous avons trouvé un plan qui
apparemment indiquent ses conclusions
définitives au sujet des terres
inconnues
et tenter un nouveau voyage je vais
traverser la calotte glaciaire pour
récupérer les documents qu'ils ont
laissé derrière eux je voudrais revenir
les goûts
c'est comme marcher de moscou à rome à
la recherche d'un tas de cailloux
on va le trouver en plus ferme
aucune trace de vie j'ai même pas vu un
voisin
quand vous faites ça à risquer votre vie
pratiquement seul vous n'avez pas un
être cher qui vous attend chez vous
jamais quand on n'y arrivera pas
les américains avaient tort
groenland et une seule terre
ne croit mort si nous n'en voyons pas un
bateau non seulement nous les
abandonnons
mais nous abandonnons également le
groënland tu sais que personne ne va
venir vous chercher je sais il m'est
impossible de justifier une dépense
supplémentaire pour une autre mission
infructueuse
supporter
son parti
vous croyez qu'on n'y arrivera pas
si on n'y arrive pas on perdra tout